[Música]
revisamos ahora los titulares de la
prensa internacional con rosa pérez más
de euro rosa bienvenida a feliz martes
para usted muy buen día vamos a hablar
de lo que pasó ayer tras la caída de
facebook también instagram y también de
whatsapp todas las propiedades del
magnate marzo con ver empezamos con el
york times que titula facebook es más
débil de lo que creemos buenos días raúl
exactamente nos hemos querido fijar en
como primero distintos medios
estadounidenses no han abordado el poder
de facebook y ha tras esta caída y
fijándose no tanto precisamente en esta
caída más técnica sino más bien en lo
que ha representado la publicación de
esta investigación que aquí hemos
comentado los papeles de facebook
publicada por el wall street journal y
tal como comentabas en los noticieros se
trata de esta ex empleada de facebook y
francis haugen quien pasó al medio pues
distintos informes internos de la
compañía y precisamente esta columna del
new york times' de kevin rudd que está
especializado en temas de tecnología
pues defiende cómo está informaciones
que se han dado a conocer muestran como
facebook pues se está perdiendo poder y
como es perfectamente consciente de esta
pérdida de influencia y como sus
decisiones empresariales están movidas
por este pánico y como ejemplo pone un
tema que también comentamos aquí que es
esta necesidad un poco desesperada de
atraer a tweet al público preadolescente
antes de que entre en el mundo de las
plataformas digitales a través de por
ejemplo tick tock y dice todavía es
pronto para decir que facebook ha muerto
pero eventualmente puede pasar en los
próximos años que pueden ser más
turbulentos todavía para para la
compañía de lo sea que han venido siendo
estos últimos así es rosa vamos ahora
con the washington post la promesa de
facebook no son tranquilizadoras son una
mala broma así titula exacto porque lo
que defiende en este caso eugene
robinson que también es un columnista
del washington post es que facebook en
mientras siga ganando dinero pues a
través de mantener a los usuarios
adictos a sus plataformas o bien a
través de la propagación de
desinformación que la puerta también
usuarios y publicidad porque recordemos
que el mayor sustento económico de
facebook todavía es la publicidad pues
no hará nada para solucionarlo entonces
propone dos soluciones por un lado dice
que se trate a facebook como un medio de
comunicación es algo que ha estado sobre
la mesa varias veces o por otro lado que
facebook sea más transparente con los
algoritmos que utiliza y cómo funcionan
dice en ambos casos esto
necesitaría de más empleados
humanos para entendernos pero dice el
status quo es insostenible rosa y vamos
ahora para cerrar este tema con de berge
eso es mira queríamos simplemente
redirigir a todos los que estén
interesados en un aspecto más técnico
sobre la caída de facebook de ayer
porque este medio de bears es
especializado en ciencia y tecnología y
cuenta de una forma pues muy eso
especializada pero también muy didáctica
no lo que pasó ayer pues en las horas de
la tarde de aquí del continente
americano ahora pasamos a otra visión
seguimos con el mismo tema pero ahora
visto desde un medio ruso vamos con el
moscú time rush ya promociona la
soberanía redes sociales tras la caída
de facebook como lo abordan los rusos
los rusos insisten en esta voluntad de
ser pues independientes no de estas
plataformas digitales estadounidenses y
así lo declaró la portavoz del ministro
de exteriores no que insistió en esta
necesidad de soberanía y él quiso
recalcar pues que telegram que fue
desarrollado precisamente por los
hermanos duros dos ciudadanos rusos pues
ganó 50 millones de usuarios ayer
mientras que facebook estuvo caído pero
es que recordemos pues los rusos acusan
a marck zuckerberg de monopolio pero es
que no sólo los rusos también en su
propio país la autoridad de la
competencia recordamos está apelando una
sentencia para pues eso acusar a
facebook de monopolio rosa cambiamos
ahora de tema también un tema del día
aquí en francia 24 y en directo américa
vamos a ver como la prensa francesa
titula el informe sobre los abusos a
menores por parte de personal que
trabajaba en la iglesia católica también
están ahí por supuesto metidos los
sacerdotes empezamos con limón
pedofilia criminalidad un balance
devastador para la iglesia católica
eso es pues nos hemos querido fijar en
como lo tratan estos tres medios
distintos lo subraya una cosa dice más
allá de los de los números absolutos que
se han dado a conocer en este informe
dice quizás lo más preocupante son los
términos relativos y es que pues se
destaca este informe como la iglesia
católica es la institución después de la
familia y el ámbito más cercano donde
más violaciones sexuales a menores se
producen media par de rózsa iglesia
francesa el informe de la vergüenza que
duró este título si si raúl es sea de
clarísimo mira media parte destaca hemos
querido pues a analizarlo por este punto
de vista como considera que francia va
tarde respecto de otros países como eeuu
irlanda australia o países bajos que ya
habían realizado este tipo de
investigaciones antes pero también
destaca como la iglesia española sí que
va por detrás de todos porque de momento
se niega a cualquier investigación y
cerramos de este tema con liberación la
iglesia católica dejó hacer
eso es liberación mira destaca otro
punto y es como pues los supervivientes
de estos abusos pues han encontrado en
el hecho de poder testificar ante esta
comisión una liberación de la palabra
rosa muy brevemente como el volcán
cumbre vieja pues raúl hemos querido
también señalar una cosa y es que la
radiotelevisión canaria este medio
público regional de españa de las islas
canarias pues tiene un vídeo en el que
uno puede hacer el seguimiento y ver
pues en directo cómo va la evolución de
la explosión de este volcán estos son
imágenes de la noche pero si uno entra
en radiotelevisión a canarias lo puede
seguir y solo recordar que precisamente
hoy el gobierno de españa pues aprobó un
nuevo paquete de 206 millones de horas
de euros en ayuda para para esta región
regresa gracias por la información
impresionantes imágenes seguimos mañana
con más titulares de la prensa mosco
nuestro invitado del día